it's a brief Serene moment but at any
second rocket fire could tear through
this
rainbow just beyond a few hundred meters
away lies Southern Lebanon and this
kabut has been hit multiple times yes
yes where locals here say Hezbollah
Fighters backed by Iran are watching
closely they point to a Hilltop military
position perched right above on the
Lebanese side you cannot raise children
here
when they go in the morning to the
kindergarten and you afraid that a
rocket will hit the
kindergarten we're in kibuts
Malia where that kindergarten has been
turned into Army
Barracks this is one of the closest
Israeli communities to the Lebanese
border peace time population 500 these
days a ghost town normal days you hear
sounds of kids running around here
um I hear sounds of
bombs this is Israel's response to an
earlier attack by
Hezbollah in fact this has been the
soundtrack of daily life in Northern
Israel since October
7th back and forth attacks and counter
attacks with a militant group that has
warned it is not afraid of war with
Israel where forces have been
intensifying drills preparing for
combat these communities are in direct
line of fire so close to the Lebanese
border that can hear the sound of
missiles and Rockets coming in before
the air eight Sirens can even
sound hasbullah is believed to be 10
times stronger than Hamas and a full
scale attack could easily
overwhelm Israel's missile defense
system an Iron Dome will not take care
of 4,000 rockets on residential areas
it's a great weapon we're really proud
of it it's not a real Iron Dome we're
not in
Hollywood in kibuts Sasa hardly anything
could have stopped the anti-tank missile
that hit the auditorium just a few weeks
ago Angelica Civ an Italian Israeli is a
theater teacher here this is the way to
my house I we can't we can't go in this
what do you
fear we fear that they see us because
all the time they see with the you know
with did and all the
time they can they can they can shoot a
greater fear is that what Hamas did on
October 7th in the South could be
replicated by Hezbollah in the
north Danielle hamam Jin global news on
the Israeli Lebanese border